-Hey, guys, it is time
for our latest installment
of "Tonight Show Polls."
Here we go.
-♪ Tonight Show Polls ♪
-These are polls.
Polls are very popular.
-True, people love them.
-Yeah, people love them.
Adults love them,
kids love them.
-Everybody loves them --
grandpa, grandma.
-Grandpa loves them?
-No.
-He doesn't like them.
-Yeah.
-He likes the poles more
at the strip club.
[ Laughter ]
-I wish -- I --
I wish my grandma liked polls.
-Why?
What's the matter?
-Huh?
-Why doesn't your grandma
like polls?
She loves polls.
Every time I --
Every time I go
to your grandma's house,
it's like she goes --
she would read polls to me.
-Sorry.
I hate to interrupt you.
You didn't hear what happened?
-No.
-Last -- Last Christmas.
-Right.
-We're out at the house...
-Yeah.
-...having some eggnog,
stuff like that.
I think she was probably is
medicated or something.
-Well, she has a lot of meds,
sure, yeah.
-Yeah, but she was wearing her
wig and everything, it was cute,
to have her over there.
-Oh, she's funny.
-Never mind. I don't even
want to talk about it.
-What happened?
What happened?
-What?
-What happened?
-Well, it was Christmas Eve.
And I don't know,
she was stumbling home.
-Yeah?
-And, uh, my grandma
got run over by a reindeer.
-Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
Where?
-On the way to her house.
-On Christmas Eve?
-Yeah.
-Oh, my God.
Did that shake your faith
in Christmas?
-No, no,
me and grandpa still believe.
[ Laughter ]
Well, here we go.
This is polls now.
-Polls, yeah.
-This first poll asks...
-Oh, wow.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's easily his favorite.
This next poll asks...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Hello."
-Next poll asks...
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's true.
It's the only one.
That's the best.
That's the best one.
-Fantastic bowl.
-This next poll asked...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This last one asked...
Well, that's all the time we
have for "Tonight Show Polls."
When we come back,
we're playing "True Confessions"
with Derek Jeter and Rita Ora.
Come on back, everybody.